that is really making some noise they
have dealt with a lot of injuries
they've had their covet outbreak as well
as thompson there's his first basket in
his return
right off the bat everybody's going
going crazy on this you know just so
happy for this guy and just have the
first shot go down may take a little bit
of that nervousness away
seven-point game warriors with a lead
thompson just the two points and this
team dribbling oh
exploding to the rim
clay thompson powers one down
acl injury was the left leg the achilles
the right achilles
in the half court and in transition
helping cleveland get back in this game
play thompson for three there it is
as he tries to make his way back it's
toscano anderson on the floor and
there's thompson he gets loose and just
like he did to start the game he scores
the first basket of the second half
started two for eight he's four for four
cents
carlo has a flurry of moves i'm sure he
is hoping to get loose here at some
point
and relatively quiet thompson yes
and has seven points in this third
quarter already step
stevens looting nice hands force the
turnover warriors in transition thompson
he'll square it up
he's already got seven in this quarter
klay thompson getting it rolling his
teammates love it the crowd loves it
love what's going on right now
[Applause]
thompson with his second three of the
game he's come out hot in this third
quarter
15 point game now cleveland
was marking it in deep mismatch on paper
oh thompson with a block coming over for
help
started the game tonight like he was
going to be on far
fire but it didn't turn out that way
klay thompson
great help defense and a block here as
marking turns to shoot comes from behind
jd picker staff's got to be very very
happy with their half court defense and
their rebounding has been better 20
offensive rebounds for golden state on
the night
this time it's looney
off the window who scores it for the
warriors